all right so we've talked about the
model and the view but you also may have
noticed the octopus object floating
around now what the heck is it doing
well as we discussed before the octopus
is what is tying our model and our view
together now you may have noticed that
the model and the view both never
directly talk to each other and that's
by design our octopus is the only thing
that connects them I like to imagine the
octopuses a sort of buffer connecting
the view in the model but also letting
them move more independently than if
they were wired directly together that
means you can change how your app looks
without messing up your model code and
vice versa so the octopus is doing
things to help out our view and to help
out our model let's go through those
things our ad Pizza function gets called
by the view and adds a pizza to the
model and lastly tells the view to
update itself our remove pizza function
is also called by the view whenever you
click on one of the little X's it
figures out what Pizza was clicked and
it sets the clicked pizzas visibility to
false and once again
it calls view dot render you may notice
these are the only two places that our
data object our model gets mutated or
changed once again the view never
changes the model directly only the
octopus now we've got two more functions
to go get visible pizzas is a function
it's almost like a tunnel that the view
uses to get the data from the model so
rather than the view saying hey model
what pizzas do we have the model asks
the octopus and the octopus goes and
gets the pizzas now why doesn't the view
just do it directly well there are two
reasons first of all as we discussed
before it's very important to separate
out your view and your model if you
don't you end up with some pretty nasty
code as your project gets bigger but the
second reason is that this get visible
pizzas function doesn't just return the
pizzas directly to the view it actually
filters them for us it takes all the
pizzas from the model and it filters
them and it only returns any pizzas
where Pizza dot visible is true
so if we go back over here to our
application and you add a whole bunch of
pizzas and then you remove a bunch of
them the way the application works is
that one two seven sixteen and seventeen
in this case these all exist in the
model but so do all of the other pizzas
we ever made that get visible pieces
function in the middle on the octopus is
taking all of the pizzas and only giving
the visible ones to our view and lastly
we have our octopus dot in it when you
call that it does all the necessary
things to get our application up and
running in this case the only thing it
has to do is tell the view to initialize
itself so once again big picture if you
have your model and your view your
octopus is the thing that connects them
to each other they never talk directly
so all of these functions are different
ways of getting between the model and
the view